i think it's sort of easier for you as
an inexperienced designer to come up
with something different hi i'm james
dyson i'm here to answer your questions
from twitter this is design support
[Music]
so first up from murat dimiroba what is
the best designed joy to use product in
your life and i've got it right here
and i bought it in japan about 30 years
ago what makes this pencil sharpener
special and better than all the ones
i've come across the other ones are
plastic and often when you put the
pencil in the thing topples over whereas
this is made of cast aluminium so it's
very heavy and actually it was quite
heavy to carry home from the shop and
bring all the way back from japan it
just works very well doesn't slip around
on the table looks good it's got spots
to store pencils in it and it's worked
for me unfailingly for 30 years the sort
of joy of putting this in and coming out
with a lovely sharp end and the noise it
makes it's just delightful this one's
from rast what is the worst design of
plants you own
and that's a really easy one to answer
and it's a printer
the next question is from doug collins
ux
who are your design heroes and why
well one of my design heroes is alex
agonis who designed the mini what i
really like about the mini which is also
true of the wartman
is when they did some research to find
out whether the mini would sell this
tiny car only ten foot long with tiny
wheels the market research said it
wouldn't sell
nobody would want a car with suddenly
little wheels like that it was just too
small
of course ultimately it became one of
the best selling cars in history and was
still being made 50 years later what i
what i really like about that
is that the khari design
looks as good today as it did in the
late 50s and that's because it's not
styled it's the sort of opposite of
harvey earl javier is the sort of
designer i hate because it's all fancy
wings and it's very showy it's design
put there to appeal to people to make it
sell and this is another and the
interesting thing about the sony walkman
is that
it's a tape recorder that won't record
and that's really really brave because
again they went and asked people do you
want to buy this tape recorder that
doesn't record it just plays back and
everybody said no and absolutely
nonsense everybody wants a tape recorder
that can record but akio morita at sony
had the bravery to see that actually
although no one says they want it he
believed they would want it because they
could put in their pocket and play music
with with earphones which no one had
ever really been able to do before the
next one's quite funny
the next question from salvatore.com
he says how does such an even light work
you create suction by developing a very
high-speed airflow so you have an
electric motor here and a turbine here
and if you turn that very very fast and
we we go about 130 000 rpm with that the
air
is drawn in to the center here and spun
out of the periphery of that turbine at
great speed
and it's so fast that
it draws in more and more air huge
amounts of air and expels them at very
high speed and if you're if you're
drawing in a lot of air into this device
you're creating suction
so that's what suction is next question
is from jose ortega product designers
what was your biggest challenge to
overcome lack of experience
how did you overcome it very
interestingly i think a lack of
experience is a great help an expert
thinks he knows it all but he's also
rather inhibited by his experience his
knowledge and he finds it difficult to
steer off the well-known path whereas if
you have a lack of experience but huge
curiosity and you approach your new
challenge with naivety i think it's sort
of easier for you
as an inexperienced designer to come up
with something different and to follow a
different path i'll give an example when
i when i started to develop my cyclonic
vacuum cleaner separation system
separating dust from air i went to the
experts and they said you'll never make
a cyclone that clears
dust out of air
below 20 microns and 20 microns is a bit
too big because a lot of dust is like
cigarette smoke it's half a micron or
0.3 of a micron but because of my
naivety i thought well
maybe he's wrong and i'll try and make
it work so five and a half thousand
prototypes later i had made it work and
i'd got it down from 20 microns down to
0.3 of a micron i'd advance the science
from being a complete novice
from mrs sloper what do i do if i have
an invention
idea the first thing you should do is
build a prototype and as soon as you
have a product that works you should
then file for a patent if you
go and file a patent before you've made
it work you could get into trouble
because a patent has to be of a product
or technology or an engineering idea
that works and you have to prove that it
works and i'm sometimes asked whether
you can contract out the making of a
prototype to a development company or
model builder or something and indeed
you can do that and if it's a purely
visual model i think that's a perfectly
good thing to do but if it's anything
mechanical or something that has to work
or has a technology you that you've got
to make to work it's much much better
you do it yourself because
when you come to and i hope you don't
ever have to do it but you have to fight
a patent action one of the first things
that the person you're accusing of
copying will say to you or their lawyers
will say to you did you build that
prototype yourself what they'll try and
argue is that you didn't make the
invention at all it was the person who
built the prototype who made the
invention i also think that the act of
making it yourself actually physically
making the prototype it's vital to do
that yourself so you fully understand
what you're doing and when it fails as
it probably will as mine always do i
understand why it's failed and i get an
idea as to how i might make it work
the next one's from frank lagandique
quick question out of curiosity
what are your biggest challenges
currently as a ux designer product
designer or product manager owner the
biggest challenge is speed getting a
product done quickly it takes nowadays a
lot of people you have to have a lot of
mechanical designers and product
designers but also you have to have a
lot of fluid dynamics motor engineers
software people ballistics people have a
whole host of people you didn't have to
have 20 25 years ago and increasingly
because
other countries are developing
technology and products so quickly we've
got to compete with that
so i would say our biggest single issue
is that we've got to do things quicker
next question which is a bit of a
personal one from anika for pres
it's 2021 and how are hand dryers not
quite yet well i agree with you i have
great sympathy for you but um we're
dealing with airflow devices that go at
120 140 000 rpm
any fast turbine moving air is noisy
think of jet engines when we're
designing new generations of hand dryers
and we've just brought one out actually
it's much quieter and we've dropped it
down to 750 watts from 1200 watts so
we're getting better at it and you're
quite right to complain about it from
charonica
a bladeless fan this is sorcery
how does dyson do it bladeless fan came
about because we were looking at airflow
technology if you let out a small blade
of air very high speed jet of air along
a particular surface actually a surface
not unlike an aircraft wing we noticed
that it sucked in from behind it a lot
of extra air and we did a circular blade
annulus we call it outlet of air very
tiny it was only a mill and a half wide
and we noticed that it increased the
original airflow by 20 times in the
process
the airflow was very smooth it wasn't
interrupted or turbulent whereas a fan
with blades
gives turbulent air and of course a
blade is um dangerous the bladed fans
are very difficult to clean they have
their motor in the center of the fan so
the fan is top heavy and it sort of
slumps so we put the motor at the base
so the fan was very stable
and we had it rotate around its center
of gravity so whatever position you put
it in it stayed there
so that's really how the fan came about
it was a very difficult product to
launch because when we showed it to
people they had no idea what it was they
thought it was an amplifier of some sort
from lindsay d young a question for
inventors
how easy have you found it to get your
product on major retailers shelves the
answer that is very simple it's very
very very difficult indeed they don't
know whether your new and different
product is going to sell in many cases
what they'd rather do is just have the
same products they've got before but at
a cheaper price but nowadays we have the
internet i would suggest that that
anyone who wants to approach retailers
or wants to sell a high volume of their
product should absolutely approach
retailers but at the same time and in
parallel sell direct on the internet
because apart from anything else if you
can prove it sells on the internet the
major retailers would be interested in
stocking it the next question is for mo
off the wall
how can inventors peacefully carry on
innovating when filing for a patent
itself costs thousands this is a
headache well i couldn't agree more mo
it's a terrible headache an individual
can't really afford to file a patent and
in particular file a patent in many
countries but the the system is
expensive because the examiner has to
search
through patent offices all over the
world going back many many years to see
if there is a similar invention to yours
but unfortunately it's the only
protection that inventors have and it's
the only system inventors have it's far
from perfect
it was dreamt up by henry iv in 1485 i
think it was and it stayed the same for
600 years and the 20-year life is
exactly the same as it was 600 years ago
so it jolly well needs an overhaul
and it's a system that's desperately
unfair for the individual inventor or
the small business
the next question's from beehoff it's
very interesting one what's the most
important element of design in your
opinion so i'm going to give you my
opinion which is very different to lots
of other people's opinions when i was at
the royal college of art being taught
design i discovered engineering
and i couldn't understand why
engineering was separated from design
why did you have a
white sort of coated engineer in a lab
developing technology and a designer in
a separate design studio often
completely unrelated to the company
developing the product or technology
designing the product so i thought
design should be part of engineering
like alec agonis with his mini so i i
see design as being everything about a
product from the technology to the
engineering
to the design
to how it's ergonomic it is how well it
performs and how long it lasts and what
materials it use and whether it's
sustainable or not so i see design
covering this whole broad range of
disciplines
and bringing it all together in a
seamless and uninterrupted way well
that's it for now they were really good
questions absolutely the right questions
to be answering and look forward to next
time goodbye